[Applause]
what about what about football what we
got going on football
it starts sunday and nobody has even
thought about it
that's what's crazy to me the whole
football point because there is normally
all this build up of preseason games
that you [ __ ] hate but they remind
you football is coming
you hear training camp [ __ ] every day
but now training camp is closed off even
reporters can barely get in
so there's just none of the build up and
it's just going to start sunday and i
think it's going to be lit as [ __ ]
but you're going to be like oh i forgot
dude normally there's all this
anticipation
and we haven't gotten to see any of the
build up just hard knocks but
that's it but why is that not enough
like i feel like there's
no media coming out about nfl whatsoever
there's not even like
cool story lines like shakeem griffin
got dropped alex smith is still on the
roster like you have weird stuff like
that but yeah but it's just
if you can cover it if a reporter can
cover it fully he can write about it
more fully
there's more reporters writing about it
we get into it nobody's in the bubble
i guess there are things happening in
the bubble but the bubble is also we're
hopping right into the playoffs yeah we
didn't give a [ __ ] about the regular
season games before that's right that's
right the only reason we care kind of
looking back is we're like oh milwaukee
never looked right when they got back
oh la is looking right now but i see how
they lost to portland because they were
sleepwalking in those first
games that's just preamble now we're in
the playoffs high stakes when the
regular season starts in the nfl
every game is high stakes i think we'll
be like let's go by like week two or
three i think we'll be back
nfl talk all day really i think yeah
because we're watching games we're like
in it yo
i wonder if hmm
i wonder if football being back
is enough of a catalyst to calm down
all the writing and protests that are
happening right now
in america i wonder if simply football
why basketball wasn't enough i don't
think
basketball because there's so many games
and you know there's going to be games
happening like
it almost feels like basketball's
omnipresent like you're like let me turn
on the tv yeah there's going to be some
basketball like
it's just always there football has this
way because
it's pretty much one or two days i guess
thursday every once in a while thursday
monday sunday
so but it's only four months and you
only get 16 games yeah
everything scares you super high stakes
yeah like
and not only is it super high stakes
it's like the game itself is high stakes
yeah your guy could go down any [ __ ]
game
right like anything can happen with this
[ __ ] sport
right and i just think if there's no
uh fans in the stands it's like you
don't have
the chance of this group and that group
coming together rooting for the same
team
so they're still at home doing it in the
privacy of their own home
and then once the game is over you can
go back and
root for your side politically
yeah but like when you're at the game
it's like you can have black lives
matter dude and you can have trumpet
right there but if you're both
[ __ ] netflix i mean giants fans yeah
it might just be distraction right now
not like it's going to bring us together
but more like distraction
conversation something to occupy my mind
yeah like even fantasy like
people love fantasy bro i don't really
love it but like
people are really into it and i just
wonder if that's that if there's that
extra thing
there's that extra conversation piece
there's a
driving focus for the week like every
sunday i know i'm going to be with my
friends watching these games
you know like i there is something for
me to do basketball is so omnipresent
i don't make a date with my homies to
watch a basketball game who cares
i don't think so you don't think so
election season man you know what
immediately election day isn't going to
matter
that story going but it's gonna i think
calm things down a bit
maybe it doesn't maybe it means nothing
i just wonder like the effects of
something as massive as football because
it's so weird like me ever since corona
i've i've
kind of like i've lost i haven't lost
the value but like the value of sports
has kind of like dropped a little bit
but sports used to run the news cycle
dude like
football was a 20 like a literally seven
days a week 24 hours a day 12 months a
year
four month season it made no sense they
were year round how the [ __ ] we talk
about football all year
i don't know you know you know what i
think what happened uh we took it out of
our
routine because there was no sports to
be talked about for such a long time
yeah we filled up
that time with other things yeah so now
that even though sports is back it's
still like
oh no i'm not gonna just drop the stuff
that i filled that time with
so it's like we haven't picked it back
up and soaked it into our lives the way
that sports was consuming i'm curious
i'm curious because i think you will
rediscover it like a couple weeks into
the season
if you're a football fan which i
obviously that started to happen to me a
little bit with basketball
yeah and that's some [ __ ] that happened
with my girl like we got into a routine
of me not watching sports yeah
yeah so like you know girls they just
get used to whatever you do
right that they like yeah so now that
i'm like watching some sports
it's almost like i'm watching sports on
her time yeah
it's like hold on now this is sports
time is that we took a little sabbatical
from
yeah because it's krona [ __ ] now we're
getting back to the to the regular but
it's over it's over now give your dog a
bone and then you try to take it and
they get mad possessive it's like hey
hey bone is over sports is here bone
time is done
bro it's so funny you said there's a
thing called a bully there we go he's
sick yo
my happy [ __ ] ground growling at me
one time
what's this what's this okay so it's
like this little it's it's some
edible form maybe it's like it's it's
like [ __ ] like a cow
dick i don't know if it was that look it
up they've got a bully stick look up
what it is you have to be
you know you about to find out wasabi is
a little slooty
and my dog's a little gay
so whatever it's like a dried it's
almost like uh like
jerky but the most intense form of jerky
yeah it's just a chew toy chew toy
but they can actually eat it yeah okay
you give it to i give it to cookie i try
to take the thing back from cookie right
grouse
my girl goes don't give cookie
the bully because she growls to try to
bite you
if you try to take it back and i'm
watching her
tell me this and i'm just like it is a
bull penis
yeah i told y'all i'd be knowing [ __ ]
but not real yeah yeah i believe it oh
you did oh no i wasn't
questioning them yeah but my point is
like i'm watching my girl tell me this
and she's not getting that she's
describing how she is
with sports like i'm trying to take my
sports back and she's like
like she's not having that we shouldn't
have given them corona yo we shouldn't
have given the world corona for us to
have more time with you what was uh oh
my god i can't believe i'm [ __ ]
blanking on this goddamn name
fat [ __ ] that we used to do
geico with john john gabriel
so gabris would do this [ __ ] where he
would never
talk on his phone
with his wife but he would also never
talk on his phone with his friends
when she when she called he kept
consistency
with hi the behavior with his girl and
when he wasn't with his girl
because when his wife calls him he's
with his friends right he's like babe
i'm sorry i can't go i don't like
talking phone with friends
but then when he's with his wife and one
of his friends calls him it's
yo sorry i gotta go with my wife so now
when his girl calls when he's with the
homies
she expects him to hang up
wow and if we were smart we would have
kept the same behavior
we were literally staring at the tv for
two and a half hours if it was blank
hey babe this is sports time all right i
want you to get used to this other [ __ ]
this sports time i'm committed we are
keeping it consistent
three and a half hours every sunday stay
tuned tv
staring we should have just started
playing madden or 2k or some show
that would have been it put on a
simulation game like yo we watching
sports we're watching sports babe get
used to it